-Our next guest is a talented
actress you know
from films such
as "In the Heights"
and the Scream franchise.
She stars in the latest
installment, "Scream VI."
It should be
in theaters everywhere
this Friday, March 10th.
Let's take a look.
[ Suspenseful music plays ]
[ Thudding ]
-Hey!
[ Vehicle horns blaring ]
Don't worry.
I got you.
-Are you kidding me?
-You have a better idea?
[ Thudding ]
-No.
♪♪
[ Thudding ]
-Come on.
Eyes on me.
Keep your eyes on me.
-Go!
[ Thudding ]
-[ Sobbing ]
-Oh, my God.
-I got you.
I got you.
[ Thudding ]
-[ Grunts ]
[ Laughter ]
-Please welcome to the show
Melissa Barrera, everybody.
[ Band plays mellow funk ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome!
I'm so happy to have you here!
-I'm so happy. This is my first
late night show ever.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Well, you're doing a great job.
[ Whistling ]
Usually --
Usually, first timers
just wander off
and you made it right over here.
-Well, so far, I didn't trip,
which was what I was afraid of.
-I remember the first time
I was on a talk show,
that was my biggest concern,
was just like
making it fully
to the couch okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. So, so far, so good.
-You're off to a great start.
Off and running.
-Thanks.
-Congratulations on the movie.
I know you had the premiere here
and was it fantastic?
-It was incredible.
It was last night
at the Lincoln Center AMC
and it was so magical.
We didn't get a premiere for the
last one because, you know,
Omicron.
-Right, right.
[ Laughter ]
-And so this was like
a double whammy premiere
and it felt big and it was
wonderful and magical.
-And, you know, I've lived
in the city for, you know,
over 20 years and I will say,
when a big horror movie
comes out,
there is no more fun place
to see it than Times Square.
[ Laughter ]
I mean that genuinely,
like those crowds
are exactly the kind of crowds
that have the sort of fun
that you're supposed
to have at movies like this.
-I mean, horror is such a like
a communal experience.
You need to see it with people
because people are shouting
and yelling at the screen
and gasping
and it's contagious
and it's fun to do that.
-This is you
with some of your costars.
You all look wonderful,
but this is even more exciting.
This is your family joined you
and they were all there.
And were they so proud?
Were they so happy?
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Yeah. That's my sister Rossana;
my mom;
my husband;
and my baby sister, Mayela.
And my other sister, Regina,
who lives in Spain,
couldn't be here.
But to me,
the most important thing
is sharing my work
with my family,
so, the fact that they all
made it out was really special.
-Now, of course, anybody
who's watching a "Scream" movie
is trying to guess
who is Ghostface,
who's behind the mask.
Your family,
did they participate in that?
Were they trying
to figure it out?
They do, because I don't
tell them anything.
-Really?
Do they try
to get it out of you
or they know
that it's pointless?
-Every day, they try.
-Okay, gotcha.
[ Laughter ]
They try to like catch me
off-guard.
But I don't --
I am really bad
when I start oversharing,
so, I just say
I'm not going to tell anyone.
And that means not even my mom,
not my husband, not anyone, so.
They get to participate
in the whodunit mystery
and they get to --
And I love watching them
watch the movie
for the first time
and they're like real reactions
and it's really -- it's cool.
-That's good. And did any
of them correctly guess?
Did they admit
to you afterwards?
-No, they did not, yeah.
-Alright. That's even more fun.
-Yeah. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
It is fun.
-There is a scene,
a fantastic scene --
This movie takes place
in New York City,
which is a first
for the Scream franchise.
There's this very scary scene
that takes place on the subway.
-I really apologize
to all subway users
[ Laughter ]
in New York City.
-Now, I will say
it's bad enough,
even without the slashers...
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-...like without Ghostface,
like it wasn't like people
were like, "Oh, the subways were
great until that."
[ Laughter ]
-I know.
-But was it fun to shoot it here
in New York
and to bring the franchise here?
-We did shoot in New York.
-Well, that is heartbreaking.
[ Laughter ]
-I know.
-I guess that makes sense.
I didn't see Ghostface
running around.
[ Laughter ]
-I know.
Well, have you seen him like
standing on corners creepily
as part of like the marketing?
-That's not okay, by the way.
-I know!
[ Laughter ]
I know it's not!
-Yeah.
-I actually am not sure
if it's part of the marketing
or if it's just someone decided
to do that and made the news.
-Like there's
a Times Square Elmo,
but that's not "Sesame Street."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-That's not a reminder
to tune in.
-But they built --
So, in Mont--
We shot in Montreal.
They had a whole soundstage
and they built a subway
with a station
and the train would go in
and out of the station,
inside a studio.
It was mind-blowing.
And it was dirty, too.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-Very accurate.
[ Laughter ]
-Now, I remember
when I saw the first "Scream"
movie in theaters --
I know I'm older than you --
I Googled it.
That's how I know. I didn't --
[ Laughter ]
Like at first, I was like,
"Are we the same age?"
But no.
[ Laughter ]
So, I'm assuming you did not see
the first one in theaters,
but you must've seen --
remember the first time
you saw the "Scream" movie.
-I do remember.
I didn't see it when it came out
because I was six, but I --
[ Laughter ]
-Don't. It's not important
how old you are.
[ Laughter ]
-I did -- I was obsessed
with horror movies
when I was like 10, 11, 12.
And I wasn't allowed
to watch horror movies,
so, I would either lock myself
in my room
or, at sleepovers
with my friends,
watch "Scream"
and "Final Destination"
and, you know, "I Know What You
Did Last Summer"
and all those obsessively.
I'm kind of a masochist that way
[ Laughter ]
because I love
watching horror movies
and I cannot sleep at night,
but I kind of love that,
weirdly, yes.
-Do you remember the first one
that really scared you,
was it one of the --
-Yes, "Chucky."
[ Laughter ]
-"Chucky," yeah.
-Yeah.
-"Chucky's" not okay,
either, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-It was not okay.
I specifically remember
this scene where he's --
It's like a back --
the back of like a big like
moving truck or something
and he's --
like the little doll
is holding someone hostage --
however that happens --
[ Laughter ]
and someone's following in a car
or running or something
and the little doll
just flips them off.
[ Laughter ]
And it's actually hilarious,
but it was so scary
to me at the time.
[ Laughter ]
-I like that,
of all of Chucky's crimes,
-I know!
-the one you couldn't stand for
is rudeness.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-That's what I remember.
-I think that says
you're a very polite person.
Of the many things we should
take away, it's that.
Hey, congratulations
on the movie.
It was so delightful
to have you here.
You're a pro.
Let me just tell you,
-Thank you.
Thank you so much.
-You're a pro at being
a talk show guest.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Melissa Barrera, everybody.
"Scream VI" will be in theaters
everywhere this Friday.
We'll be right back
with Margaret Atwood.